c'est aujourd'hui la journée nationale
du don d'organes et de la greffe et en
indre et loire les nouvelles ne sont pas
bonnes sur le front des transplantations
avec la crise sanitaire des greffes ont
dû être reportés en 2020 au chu de tours
et cette année les dons d'organes font
aussi défaut des explications de thibaut
bruch
il fait partie des belles histoires du
chu de tours depuis quelques années
comme près de 60000 français pascal
atteint d'une cardiomyopathie vit
aujourd'hui avec le coeur d'un total
étrangers j'ai vu simplement mon état de
cardiaque qui diminuait de plus en plus
sans cette greffe je ne serais pas là
malheureusement pour vous parler
aujourd'hui puisqu'il ne me restait plus
que quatre heures à vivre
donc ce cadeau de dons d'organes qui est
arrivé est arrivé vraiment au moment où
ils en avaient le plus besoin pour
continuer ma vie
face à la pandémie de kovy de 19
les hôpitaux ont été soumis à rude
épreuve dépression comme pascal il y en
a de moins en moins en 2020 et en 2021
au chu de tours
le constat est sans appel n'a vraiment
constaté une baisse très importante du
nombre de transplantations rénales ici
par exemple à toi on fait brutalement
entre 140 et 150 transplantation par an
on est descendu à 115 120 et donc le don
c c'est la base de la greffe ya pas bref
s'il ya pas de doute depuis le début de
l'année 2021
les prélèvements d'organes sont en
baisse entre 15 et 20% à tour en cette
journée nationale de la réflexion autour
du don d'organes les spécialistes en
appelle à la responsabilité de chacun
pour promouvoir une pratique qui sauvent
près de six mille vies chaque année en
france
c'est un très très important que les
gens en parlent entre eux tout le monde
peut être donneur mais tout le monde
peut aussi malheureusement un jour être
en attente de greffe la loi bien entendu
nous dit qu'on est tous donneurs nous
sommes tous donneurs qu'on n'a pas
exprimer notre refus et je pense que le
plus important c'est que les gens
parlent entre eux en france près de 20
mille patients restent aujourd'hui en
attente d'une greffe tout organe
confondues